what up guys this is my first video in
one week yes up about five or six days I
was on Virginia visiting family Easter
blah blah all that I was on spring break
but now I'm back I didn't have internet
connection the entire time down there so
I had to use my grandparents internet
connection which was extremely slow but
I can only answer emails on this which
means I couldn't answer YouTube comments
I could only post comments and rate and
I couldn't really active I couldn't be
that active on YouTube basically but now
you can see the same old formula
surroundings so I am obviously back and
there will be more hardware and software
videos tutorials HD all that stuff it
will be back so I've got a few cases in
the mail there will be unboxings I'm I'm
starting to use this camera more on for
my unboxing video so I'll get the best
quality out of my videos you'll be able
to see everything in the highest quality
and they'll be pretty pretty clear for
you guys so basically if you have
subscribed I thank you already and
please stay subscribed because there are
a lot more videos to come I have a whole
lot more ideas I have a notepad document
I have so many more things I got to show
you guys so thanks for subscribing and
thanks for watching my videos it's